joe biden tells american companies to
follow his vaccine mandate even though
it's unconstitutional as the price of
gas rises at the pump biden shuts down
another pipeline and iconoclastic
intellectuals open a new university i'm
ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with vpn so should you
visit expressvpn.com
ben well we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first pretty monumental
news out there it was recently announced
that social security benefits are going
to increase by almost six percent in
january that's the highest increase in
40 years which is the government
admitting because they have to that
inflation is spiraling and yet the left
is still attempting to push through
trillions in more spending we got the
infrastructure bill now we got buildback
better being rammed through by biden
well if you are worried about the price
of the dollar if you are worried about
the level of the dollar you should be
protecting your savings with gold and
silver from birch gold group now an
incentive for you to do so this month
when you text ben to 47 47 47 and
purchase precious metals with birch gold
by december 23rd you'll get free silver
for every five thousand dollars you
invest and yes you can convert an
eligible ira or 401k into an ira backed
by precious metals that qualifies as
well birch gold has an a plus rating
with the better business bureau
countless five-star reviews thousands of
happy customers text ben to
47-47-47 for your free no obligation
information kit on holding gold and
silver in a tax sheltered account and to
claim your free silver with qualifying
purchase by december 23rd text ben to 47
47 47 protect your savings today
alrighty so
joe biden's unconstitutional vaccine
mandate was held up in the fifth circuit
court of appeals and that is not
stopping the white house from attempting
to force businesses to perform this
vaccine mandate anyway
now imagine that trump had said this
imagine if there had been some sort of
order from trump and a court had said
don't do it we got to take a look at
this and trumpets should say had just
said americans i want you to ignore the
courts and do what i tell you to do
right now
how do you think the media would have
responded would we have gotten a lot of
talk about the authoritarian nature of
the trump administration you betcha
which we've gotten a lot of talk about
the breaking of the constitutional
system the constitutional crisis that
was now coming to a head of course but
when democrats say that courts no longer
matter and you're supposed to just
ignore what courts say then of course
it's not a problem at all because they
are seeking progress according to cnbc
the white house on monday said
businesses should move forward with
president joe biden's vaccine and
testing requirements for private
businesses despite a federal appeals
court ordering a temporary halt to the
rules people should not wait said white
house deputy press secretary karen
jean-pierre they should continue to move
forward and make sure they're getting
their workplace vaccinated
the u.s court of appeals halted the
requirements saturday pending review
writing the petitions give cause to
believe there are grave statutory and
constitutional issues with the mandate
and of course it's not just the circuit
court of appeals we here at the daily
wire we have filed a lawsuit against the
biden administration in the sixth
circuit court of appeals along with a
bunch of other attorneys at general
in its response monday evening the biden
administration asked the court to lift
the pause dismissing the states and
companies claims of harm as premature
given that the deadlines for vaccination
and testing are not until january the
administration claimed that pausing the
requirements would likely cost dozens or
even hundreds of lives per day as the
virus spreads of course their
information on this is really really
scanty because again the rule in the
united states is if you can get a
vaccine it is now up to you that really
should be the rule in a free country the
labor and justice department's also
urged that osha acted within its
authorities established by congress now
the the bite administration is so ugly
what they're doing here with regard to
this vaccine mandate instead of playing
a game they said two months ago that it
was an emergency and thus osha was going
to promulgate a regulation under
emergency temporary standards that was
going to be necessary because of the
emergency right the house was on fire
two months from now we're going to bring
the fire hose then they promulgated the
regulation and the regulation doesn't go
into effect until january now here's the
problem if you're a business and you are
seeking to comply with the mandate
before january because you want to get
as many people vaccinated as possible if
you wish to avoid the fines you have to
kick that into place pending the federal
government actually punishing you but
what the biden administration is saying
is that until there's the possibility of
us actually finding you until january
you can't sue
so they're saying is the mandates don't
kick into place formally until january
but you really need the next couple of
months to get ready this is why the
courts of appeals are holding this thing
up because they're saying well the
punishment doesn't come down until
january what you are requiring of people
takes time to implement which means that
effectively speaking you are forcing
them to do things right now so they
don't get fined in january but the buy
administration is trying to end around
that specifically by delaying all this
and by the way delaying it until after
the holidays if it were really so vital
why wouldn't they make this effective
inside of two weeks
why instead are they waiting until after
the holidays we all know the answer it's
because we already have a massive supply
chain crisis and if you knock out a
significant percentage of the workforce
and i mean even a marginal percentage of
the workforce could be significant when
you already have supply chain
bottlenecks
when you do that you exacerbate the
problem so the bite administration wants
to have its cake you need it to they
want to promulgate the regulation they
want to do so without harming the
economy and they want to do so even
though it's unconstitutional and by the
way not done properly under the
emergency temporary standards rules
because normally the way that you
promulgate a rule at a regulatory agency
is you have to have a comment and review
period you have to have the public give
their input on how the regulation should
actually be written
and it takes a while to promulgate these
regulations under emergency temporary
standards
places like osha just issue a rule no
comment period but
now they're saying that they want to
issue the rule no comment period have it
effective in two months and that's four
months after the original announcement
by biden this is why courts are holding
it up it's a really corrupt and stupid
little game that they are playing here
and again the goal here is to force you
to do things even though you have no
legal or constitutional obligation to do
them
and in the end politically speaking what
it's really about is joe biden and his
administration attempting to say to
their base we did all we could even
though it's gonna get struck down in the
same way that they pushed the cdc
eviction moratorium even though they
knew that it was gonna get struck down
by the supreme court almost immediately
they did it so that biden could tell his
progressive base that he had done
something
the court ordered pause came a day after
the requirements went into effect
starting the countdown for businesses
with a hundred or more employees to
ensure their staff have received the
shots required for full vaccination by
january 4th after that date according to
cnbc unvaccinated workers must submit a
negative covenant test weekly to enter
the workplace and all unvaccinated
workers must start wearing face masks
indoors at their workplaces starting on
december 5th
so it's a good shot at this point that
it ends up in front of the supreme court
i have a feeling the supreme court is
not going to be particularly friendly
toward this regulation
all of which means that that so much of
what is going on right now
for the biden administration is about
posturing and prolonging the patent
they're in a box of their own making as
i've said one million times at this
point this administration came into
office pledging that they would end
covet
no administration has the power to end
an endemic disease that does not exist
there is no magic button you can hit
that ends covet so they've made a
promise they can't keep the promise if
they admit they can't keep the promise
then it looks like they're incompetent
if they continue to push then they're
just being restrictive and terrible and
this does have downstream effects
because when you make a promise and you
keep saying no that we will keep pushing
we will keep pushing we will ensure that
this disease disappears it causes people
to make bad decisions
and that affects the economy and it
affects your life as well we'll get to
that in just one moment first
let us talk about a simple fact if
you're a responsible person you need
life insurance let's say that you are an
actress and for some reason you just get
roped into some bizarre voyage where you
end up on an island picking up an
enormous gorilla that's just a really
outsized gorilla you bring the gorilla
back to new york you put it on display
but this gorilla for some reason has
fallen in love with you and the gorilla
picks you up starts climbing a giant
building called the empire state
building well as you ascend into the sky
in the paw of this giant hairy mammal
you might be thinking to yourself man
should have listened to shapiro and
gotten life insurance policy genius
makes it easy to compare quotes from
over a dozen top insurers all in one
place why compare you could say 50 or
more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius it could save
1300 or more per year on life insurance
by using policy genius to compare
policies the license experts of
palestinians work for you not the
insurance companies so you can trust
them to help you navigate every step of
the shopping and buying process that
kind of service has earned policy genius
thousands of five-star reviews across
trustpilot and google and eligible
applicants can get covered in as little
as a week thanks to an award-winning
policy option swapping the standard
medical exam requirement for a simple
phone call getting started is simple
head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
compare those personalized quotes find
your best price when you're ready to
apply policy genius does the rest head
on over to policygenius.com slash appeal
gets started right now policy genius
when it comes to insurance it's nice and
quite important to get it right okay so
there are some real downstream effects
to the binding administration's
desperate clinging to the pandemic
okay so for example a lot of people
staying out of the workforce because
they're under the odd misimpression that
if they keep blaming kovid then they
will keep getting paid
now reality is starting to set in and
one of the reasons you saw an uptick in
people re-entering the workforce last
month is because of the running of
federal unemployment benefits they
finally ran last month shock of shocks
people started to go back to work but
there are a lot of people who are being
very picky about their jobs because they
have been convinced number one that
covet is
extraordinarily deadly
at this point in time when again if you
are vaccinated it certainly is not there
are very good therapeutics that are now
in the market that pfizer therapeutic is
going to be out in the next couple of
weeks it's supposed to be a pill that
reduces your chances of hospitalization
by 90 and death by a hundred percent
if you take it within the first three
days after a covert diagnosis
we are now learning that the regeneron
monoclonal antibody treatment which was
supposedly is cutting edge ridiculous
treatment why is rhonda sans pushing it
we're now learning that it actually has
about 80 effectiveness in preventing
even infection about eight months out
and that is the new data on regenerons
we have very good therapeutics we have
vaccines this means that if you wish to
be scared of covet that's because it's
your choice to be scared of covet at
this point there's really no reason for
you to be living in fear of covet when
there are good therapeutics available
when the vaccines are available
and yet people have eaten up the biden
administration theory that covid is
still going to kill you if you go
outside and also that the government is
going to continue to protect you so long
as you believe that covet is going to
kill you there is a correlation between
your level of fear and panic
and your level of trust in the
government
because here's the thing if you are a
normal person and you assess your risks
at this point and you say listen i've
done all i can covet is not that risky
to me whatever that decision may be
and then you go out and live your life
you're probably not the kind of person
who is going to trust the government to
fix all of your problems
but the government knows that government
intellectuals know that the incentive
structure for governmental actors is
always to promise they can fix all of
your problems and so you end up with
serious shortages in the workforce
there's an article in the washington
post today it's called why millions of
job seekers aren't getting hired in this
hot job market
according to heather long and eli
rosenberg even as the united states has
a near record number of job openings and
companies complain they can't find
enough workers some job seekers remain
frustrated that they've not been able to
get a job despite filling out dozens of
applications daily on popular job sites
like zipper crew indeed linkedin and
craigslist
now you may be asking yourself wait a
second if there are not enough people
who are attempting to get into the
workforce to keep up with the jobs
shouldn't everybody attempting to get
into the workforce have a job the answer
is no the reason is because job seekers
are apparently now attached to the idea
that companies are supposed to do crazy
things in order to employ them in the
first place
according to the washington post
american workers are increasingly
seeking higher pay more flexibility and
remote options as they flex their
leverage in the current job market but
many companies are not necessarily being
more accommodative continuing to favor
candidates with several years of
experience in their industry more
availability to work evening or weekend
hours or a preference for those willing
to work in person so if you read that
headline what it sounds like is that
the employers are being intransigent
when in reality employers get to dictate
the terms of the work
so long as there are willing
participants in the marketplace who are
willing to do what that requires
right jobs are a market
that it's a market like any else
and when you're an employer shopping for
an employee
the employer is the consumer at that
point not the employee the employee is
not the consumer the employer is the
consumer of the labor that means they
get to shop for what they want but
employees have been convinced by the
media that they now get to dictate terms
in incredibly stupid ways
according to the washington post while
employers have complained for months
about the difficulty they face hiring
during a labor shortage with more than
10 million job openings for 7.4 million
unemployed workers interviews with job
hunting workers revealed a concurrent
reality difficulty finding suitable work
as they navigate the pandemic labor
market so how are we defining suitable
work at this point
according to julia pollock chief
economist at zip recruiter a lot of
interest from employers is not spread
evenly across the labor pool there are
some people in very high demand there
are some people who get no interest at
all employers really do value prior
experience a lot okay now here's an
example of a person who's having a tough
time getting a job ready
lavinia hampton spent years mixing
drinks as a bartender at a popular
nightclub in downtown san antonio but
the pandemic has made her rethink her
job hampton has seen coveted infections
hobble and kill some of her friends
making her far less willing to take any
risks a friend's seven-year-old mother
who's like a second mom to hampton died
last month of covet after spending three
months in the hospital another bartender
our hampton knows contracted coveted
after returning to work ended up in the
hospital on events later few in texas
wear masks in bars and restaurants for
months hampton 40 has been scouring job
sites for work from home positions and
customer service in other fields so she
won't have to return to bartending in a
packed club i have every right to work
in a safe working environment she said i
want to work from home i want to keep
safe okay that is a person who is
keeping herself out of the workforce
she's 40 years old unless she has some
serious preexisting health condition
once she gets the vaccines she's good to
go
there are therapeutics that are
available and she's specifically saying
i'm my seven-year-old mom's friend
died of covid so i a healthy 40 year old
cannot go back to doing what apparently
i am employable at bartending
unmasked at a club
that is not logical okay it isn't
but the way the media portray this is
that if you go back to work at a bar in
texas you're going to die and some
people are staying out of the workforce
and the bite administration is therefore
using that sort of panic in order to
cram down vaccine mandates that are
unconstitutional according to the
washington post there's a growing
preference for remote work among job
seekers some 55 of people on zip
recruiter reported looking for a job
that would allow them to work from home
that's not a shock most people would
prefer to work from home rather than
going into the office the vast majority
said either workplace safety concerns or
child or family care needs or driving
their preference for remote work
hampton has not been able to land
anything and is getting desperate since
her unemployment ended over the summer
with no recent experience in many of the
jobs she's applying for companies are
reluctant to give her a chance
she says it's affecting my mental health
greatly i cry all the time i've never
been on unemployment before
now maybe the reason that you are on
unemployment is because you are making
poor application decisions where do you
have experience where can you gain
experience are you willing to take a
starting wage at a company rather than
taking what is probably a much higher
wage working at a bar like what are you
looking for
so again the idea here is that the
employers are bad and the reason the
employers are bad is because covet is
endemic and the reason that covert is
endemic is because the american people
won't listen to joe biden that seems to
be the logic here
and here's the thing this sort of panic
mentality leads to bad logic about how
we end the pandemic
in one second we'll talk about that
because the new push is we're going to
force you to vaccinate your children
that is the new push it's coming from
places like san francisco whatever
starts in san francisco goes california
wide as soon as it goes california wide
it goes blue statewide and once it goes
blue statewide it goes federal we'll get
to that in a moment first if you've been
listening to the show for a while you
probably heard me talk about my helix
sleep mattress which is what i rely upon
for my precious hours of sleep each
night but now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and they've started making sofas
they just launched a new company called
all form and making premium customizable
sofas and chairs shipped directly to
your door
so what makes an all form sofa really
cool for starters it's the easiest way
you can customize the sofa using premium
materials at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores you can pick your
fabric it is spill stain and scratch
resistant the sofa color the color of
the legs sofa size and shape make sure
it is perfect for you and your home
they've got arm chairs and love seats
all the way up to an eight seat
sectional so there is something for
everyone and you can always start small
and buy more seats later on if you want
your all form sofa to grow and change
with you when you move all form sofas
are also delivered directly to your door
in the past if you wanted to order a
sofa you need somebody to come over and
build it for you but not with all form
all form has simple quick assembly no
tools necessary again i am not the most
technically app person i'm the guy who
builds the the
weird shelf you get from ikea and leaves
out the pegs because it's actually like
super complicated not so with all form
i've been all formed so if i picked out
the three-seat sofa with chase in the
sand color with espresso legs it is so
comfortable and if getting a sofa
without trying it in store sounds risky
don't worry get 100 days to decide if
you want to keep it that's more than
three months if you don't love it
they'll pick it up for free give you a
full refund they've got a forever
warranty literally for all time and all
form is offering 20
off all orders for our listeners at
allform.com
ben so find your perfect sofa today
check out allforum.com
to get started okay so the panic
mentality the belief that government can
solve all problems in life is now
leading to particular stupidity with
regard to the treatment of children so
for this entire pandemic we had
lies about how kids needed to be out of
school or if they were in school they
needed to be masked and all of it was
based on scanty data at best when you're
talking about young kids it was based on
no data at all
now the new push is you must vaccinate
your five-year-old
now i'll be honest with you i've got a
seven-year-old a five-year-old a
one-year-old i have no plans to vax my
kids right away
i'll wait i will see what the data show
and then maybe i'll vax my kids
but i do not feel a deep and abiding
rush a necessity to rush to vaccinate my
kids why because covid is not wildly
dangerous for children across the entire
course of the pandemic for all people in
the united states under the age of 18 10
to 20 healthy kids below the age of 18
have died of covid the entire pandemic
which is about a year and a half long
now
okay that is that is not enough of a of
a basis of risk a baseline risk
for me to sit around worrying about my
kids and their and the risk of of not
only getting covered but then getting
some things here getting seriously ill
from kovid
and again the math is a little complex
here
so there's a good piece today in the
wall street journal by nicole safier and
marty mccary both of whom have been
guests on the program
mccarry of course at johns hopkins
university dr safir is an assistant
professor at memorial sloan kettering
cancer center and weill cornell medical
college they have a piece today about
whether you should be vaccinating your
five-year-old
and here's what they say the risk is
extremely low either way the centers for
disease control and prevention estimates
that 42 of us children 5 to 11 had
coveted by june 2021 before the delta
wave a prevalence that is likely greater
than 50 today of 28 million children in
that age range 94 have died of covet
since the pandemic began 562 have been
hospitalized with covid infections and
again the vast majority of those kids
had a pretty serious pre-existing
condition serious complications are so
uncommon in this age range that of the
2186 children in the pfizer vaccine
study no child in either the vaccine or
the placebo group developed severe
illness from covid sixteen of the 663
unvaccinated kids developed coveted
infections compared with only three of
the 1305 vaccinated ones an
effectiveness rate of 90.7 percent
against infection it's safe to assume
that vaccinating a healthy child would
take his extremely low risk of serious
disease and drive it down even lower
there's an important exception though if
a child has already had covered there is
no scientific basis for vaccination
even in the fisa report is this line no
cases of coven 19 were observed in
either the vaccine group or in the
placebo group in participants with
evidence of prior sars coveted to
infection
that is consistent with the largest
population based study on the topic
which found that natural immunity was 27
times as effective as vaccinated
immunity in preventing symptomatic covet
now again the cdc has cited less robust
studies for the notion that vaccination
is better than natural immunity but the
israeli study is the biggest and still
the best study on this particular topic
say mccary and safir side effects in the
study were significant but not
life-threatening the overall adverse
event rate following vaccination the
pfizer study was about 11
fever occurred in about 6.5 percent of
kids following the second vaccine dose
one case of leg numbness was reported
they don't know if the adverse events
were clustered in kids who had
circulating antibodies from prior covet
infection pfizer did not provide that
data there were no cases of myocarditis
but the sample size was too small to
rule out a complication that was found
in one out of seven thousand adolescent
boys okay the reason that i'm saying
this
is that the the baseline notion that is
now being pushed by this administration
and apparently the entire media is that
you must vaccinate your five to eleven
year old you must that's the only way to
end the pandemic in the same way that we
must force workplaces to force their
workers to vaccinate it's quote unquote
the only way to end the pandemic
or alternatively
adults get to make their own decisions
and children are pretty damn safe in the
first place
but when you have made a promise and
there is no way for you to keep that
promise you have to find other people to
blame so now you're going to blame the
families who will not vaccinate their
five-year-olds now you're going to blame
the workplaces that aren't going to
force this on their employees
now you're going to blame aaron rodgers
and you're going to blame
joe rogan and you're going to blame
everyone else who doesn't do it the way
you want it done
i don't think that's going to be a
popular pitch for the democrats but they
keep building boxes and then getting
stuck in them they're like mimes
they're constantly in invisible boxes of
their own making whether it's the box of
wokeness where they proclaim to
everybody that equity is the only thing
that matters and then they're stuck
because it turns out that equity meaning
equal outcome is impossible to achieve
absent tyranny or whether they are
saying that they can cure covid if you
give joe biden the old doddering
fool in the white house enough power
it turns out they are very bad at
solving your problems in the first place
like really really bad at it over and
over and over
and it is amazing how everything for the
bite administration is a box of its own
making let me take a quick example okay
so pete booty judge yesterday the
secretary of transportation who earned
his job because he loves airports and
choo choo trains yesterday he was asked
about racism of the highways and here's
what he had to say again you made a box
for yourself and now you're stuck
i'm still surprised that some people
were surprised when i pointed to the
fact that
if
a highway was built for the purpose of
dividing a white in the black
neighborhood
or if an underpass was constructed such
that a bus carrying mostly black and
puerto rican kids
to a beach or it would have been in new
york was was designed uh too low for it
to pass by but that obviously reflects
racism that went into those design
choices
so that was p buddha judge suggesting
that your highways are racist they keep
creating these boxes and then they can't
get out of the boxes because there is no
way to make the quote-unquote highways
unracist because again the highways are
not super racist okay like they're
they're highways we'll get to the
explanation for that in just a second
because he is referring to a thing it's
just not a thing that he he actually is
being honest about we'll get to that in
a moment first let us talk about
upgrading look and feel of your home so
if you just moved and a lot of people
have just moved this year you know that
the look and feel of your home matters a
lot and the way the light comes into a
room is really a big thing like when we
bought our new house how light entered
rooms was like the biggest it was one of
the biggest things on the agenda if you
walk into a dark room it's just
depressing well one of the things that
can actually prevent a room from looking
great is the crappy old window coverings
you need blinds.com makeblinds.com your
first choice for high quality window
coverings that are perfect for any size
window color and look you have in mind
there's no guesswork no hassle with
multiple trips to a store or trying to
meet up with a contractor or interior
designer to consult you who's really
just going to try and upsell you all of
the window treatments from blinds.com
come at a great price and are easy to
install you can handle the measure and
install yourself or have blinds.com take
care of it with local pros it's easy
with blinds.com get any size or color of
cellular shades faux wood blinds or any
other style you have in mind simply see
your vision come to life at blinds.com
those are the experts you want to go to
they've done over 25 million windows at
this point five times more than all the
windows on manhattan
there's a reason they have 40 000
five-star reviews get free samples free
shipping 100 satisfaction guarantee go
to blinds.com right now through november
11th save up to 45 off everything that's
an amazing deal as blinds.com up to 45
off when you check out online don't
forget to tell them you heard about
blinds.com from the ben shapiro show
rules and restrictions may apply okay so
and the administration keeps creating
traps for itself and then getting stuck
in the traps so they say things like
equity is the only thing that matters
equity equity equity equity and then all
of their public officials are held
accountable for this equity talk so you
have p booty judge the secretary of
transportation being asked about the
racism of the highways and answering by
saying that the highways are clearly
racist and then citing a story from
robert carro's book on robert moses the
the power broker from 1974 talking about
how robert moses who built a lot of the
public works in new york was a vicious
racist and how they had built highways
that were specifically designed to
prevent black and hispanic people from
getting to the beach it turns out that
that's not true
right so we are curing a problem that
actually does not exist at least
in the reference that he is talking
about right here p booty judge thomas
campanella wrote a piece on this back in
2017 for bloomberg pointing out there's
little question that moses held patently
bigoted views but to what extent were
those prejudices embedded in his public
works
moses was complex he gave harlem a
glorious pool and play center now jackie
robinson park one of the best public
works of the new deal era anywhere in
the united states a crowd of 25 000
attended the opening ceremony in august
1936 the 369th regiment band playing
when the music goes round and round
before parks commissioner moses was
introduced to great applause by bill
bojangles robinson
contrary to acclaim in the power broker
moses clearly meant buses to serve his
little jones beach in the rockaways at
jacob reese park while oriented mainly
toward motorists it is simply not true
that new yorkers without cars were
excluded
the original site plan included bus drop
off zones photographs from the era
plainly show buses loading and unloading
passengers bus connections with the bmt
and irt in brooklyn reported the
brooklyn eagle when the vast seaside
playground opened 80 years ago this
summer make the park easily accessible
to non-motorists
so
like he's just citing bad data in
pursuit of the idea that we have to cure
systemic racism that exists in highways
by manhattan beaches or something
when you create boxes in your own making
it's very difficult to get out of those
boxes this is also true with regard to
gas prices so the biden administration
right now is undercutting its own
economic appeal
so democrat let's just start with this
democrats got their asses kicked last
week they just got destroyed okay what
happened in virginia and new jersey
should be a shock to the system of
democrats henry olsen has a good piece
of the washington post about this he
says to understand the magnitude of last
week's electoral earthquake one must
grasp the concept of margin shift this
is the difference between one party's
winning margin and one election versus
the same margin in the next election
this measures the change in voter
attitudes can be used to assess what
might happen in other contests if the
same shift were to occur tuesday was an
utter disaster for democrats by that
assessment joe biden won virginia by
10.1 points in 2020 carried new jersey
by 15.9 points although some votes are
still being tallied the margin shift for
the gop was 12.1 points in virginia and
13.3 points in new jersey
moreover gop candidates for the
legislatures in each state obtained
nearly identical shifts
the margin shift was similar or higher
in pennsylvania or new york as well
these margins would shatter democratic
congressional majorities if they occur
in next year's midterms
according to dave wasserman he estimates
that republicans would gain between 44
house seats on the new jersey state
assembly swing and 51 on the virginia
house of delegates shift
swings on the scale of new jersey's
gubernatorial race and long island local
offices would likely push gop gains
close to the record 63 seats they picked
up in the 2010 midterms
any of those results would give the gop
more house each than at any time since
1928.
republicans would also be favored to
gain massively in the senate a 10-point
margin shift would likely cost democrats
arizona georgia nevada and new hampshire
and in either wisconsin north carolina
and pennsylvania a 12-point shift would
even put colorado in play
new york style shifts would place oregon
and washington in play now
that may not all materialize but the
bottom line is that democrats are in
serious trouble and what they should be
doing is tacking back to the center
mark penn and andrew stein were advisors
to the clintons they have a piece in the
new york times today
saying bill clinton saved its presidency
here's how biden can too
and they keep pointing out you guys need
to tack to the center they say according
to our october harvard caps harris poll
only 35 of registered voters approve of
the administration's immigration
policies 64 oppose eliminating cash bail
most reject even popular expansions of
entitlements if they're bundled in that
build back better initiative nearly 9 in
10 voters expressed concern about
inflation 61 percent of voters blame the
biden administration for the increase in
gasoline prices
so what you need to do is stop with all
of the nonsense radicalism
but is joe biden stopping with any of
the nonsense radicalism absolutely not
they keep doubling down on stupid
according to politico today president
joe biden's plans to push the country
away from fossil fuels and toward clean
energy are facing an unexpected hurdle
the price of propane in escanaba
michigan
biden took the stage in glasgow last
week to promise world leaders the us was
ready to lead the charge against climate
change but the messi pipeline fights in
the us are putting his administration in
the crossfire between environmentalists
and indigenous groups eager to block
fossil fuel projects and republicans who
are ramping up attacks blaming the white
house for soaring energy prices
biden remember he quashed keystone xl he
also greenlit the nordstrom 2 pipeline
on behalf of the russians so
you know captain anti-russia over here
was actually significantly more
pro-russia in his policies than
than donald trump ever was
now the administration is studying what
to do about a pipeline stretching across
michigan that activists and the state's
democratic governor contend poses a
catastrophic pollution risk to the great
lakes
word that the biden administration was
quietly studying the potential market
impact of killing the line 5 pipeline
first reported by politico set off a
firestorm of criticism from republicans
saying the move would worsen the spike
that has already driven propane prices
up 50 percent from a year ago just as
michigan residents are about to enter
the winter
propane stripped out of the line at the
small port city of escanaba to help feed
supplies to communities in the state's
upper peninsula
environmental groups and gretchen
whitmer are trying to shut the pipeline
down in the middle of all of this
and again this in the middle of a giant
gas price spike here's the white house
deputy press secretary yesterday
acknowledging the biden administration
is considering shutting down the line 5
pipeline
is it is it being studied right now is
the administration studying the impact
of shutting down the line 5 yes we are
we are is that
inaccurate well i thought you were
saying that we were going to shut it
down but that is that is not inaccurate
okay great great great great but uh the
army corps of engineers is preparing an
environmental impact to look through
this
so yeah they're looking at shutting it
down is the short answer there by the
way the white house spokesperson also
could not name anything that joe biden
is doing to lower gas prices
so i don't again i don't i don't have
anything specific here the president
spoke to this recently but he's also
asked ftc to crack down on illegal
pricing right that is one thing that he
did on gouging in the market and the ftc
is responding but also we're going to
continue to monitor the situation and
have a number of tools in our arsenal as
i just mentioned i don't have anything
specific
yeah they have nothing specific because
they've got nothing they've got nothing
because they're boxed in they're boxed
in by their own environmental policies i
mean joe biden has openly stated that
rising prices of gas are good because
they drive down carbon emissions
he has back policies that do this
specifically
and now he's trapped they keep making
traps for themselves and then stepping
right in the traps
i mean jennifer granholm is the
secretary of energy and she's asked
about the spiking of gas prices and she
says well you know we are focused here
on on climate change and climate change
legislation is going to create jobs yeah
good luck with this this attack here
and yes we have a short-term cost issue
because the economy is still coming back
on we have a supply that does a demand
that does not that the supply doesn't
meet the demand and that is an issue
that we are going through the president
is all over this both in the short term
and in the long term but the bottom line
for when the president says when he
hears climate change he thinks about
jobs that is critical for our long-term
strategy
uh no you guys are in real trouble here
because you again you have created an
expectation that cannot be fulfilled you
could have your cake and eat it too you
could do all this climate change
nonsense and that it wouldn't raise the
gas prices or have any impact on the
economy or have any impact on the way
americans live barack obama has been
pushing this nonsense forever so barack
obama head on headed on over to cop26
right this climate change
boondoggle that's going on over in
glasgow that's going to continue for a
couple of months it's going to host some
20 to 30 000 people because nothing says
stopping climate change like a bunch of
private jets landing on the tarmac in
glasgow and barack obama is saying that
biden's spending plan is going to reduce
energy prices yeah good luck with this
one
that legislation will devote over half a
trillion dollars
to reduce greenhouse gas emissions by
over a billion metric tons by the end of
the decade at least 10 times more than
any legislation previously passed by
congress along the way it will reduce
consumer energy costs it will invest in
a clean energy economy it will create
hundreds of thousands of jobs and it
will set the united states on course to
meet
its new climate targets
achieving a 50 to 52 reduction in
greenhouse gas emissions below 2005
levels
by 2030.
okay the part that matters there is
where he says it's going to reduce
energy costs explain explain but here's
the thing he's completely disconnected
there's an elitist group of people at
the top of the democratic party they are
completely disconnected from the people
who they say they represent
and barack obama is a perfect example of
this this dude is so disconnected i mean
besides holding his birthday party
in the middle of an area that just had
an outbreak with no masks while
proclaiming that everybody else on earth
needs to wear masks it's very very very
important while he's getting his rich
netflix his sweet netflix cash
after having basically
provided no real private sector services
to anyone over the course of his career
but he's been living on on the public
dime as a as an elected official for a
very long time then gotten super rich
after being in the white house on this
basis he's just disconnected he's
completely disconnected and and for him
he says things like i can give up a lot
of my lifestyle yeah but how about that
guy who's living at the margin how about
that family that's living at the margin
where the family just needs enough gas
in their tank to go to work without
breaking their budget they're not barack
obama barack obama has several houses
barack obama is worth tens of millions
of dollars based on the fact that he was
once president of the united states by
the way i do hold a fair bit of
resentment for politicians become rich
after being politicians it seems to me
that if you're rich before you're a
politician at least you did something
useful and then you went into politics
as public service if you went into
public service so you could leave and
become rich yeah i kind of resent that
here is barack obama talking about how
he and all of his wisdom and generosity
is happy to give up some of his
lifestyle to fight climate change the
little people you know they'll have to
pay too but he doesn't really care about
that
i can afford to give up a lot
of my current lifestyle to benefit the
planet because i'll still have a lot
left over a lot of folks don't have that
cushion so that means that any climate
plan worth at salt has to take
these inequities into account whether
it's through subsidies
to poor people to ease the transition to
clean energy whether it's technology
transfers that help poor countries meet
their development goals by leapfrogging
dirty fuels we have to pay attention
to those
embedded inequities
and the politics that surrounds that
okay but he's not going to do any of
that that's the point the standards that
he is setting don't do any of that
are you subsidizing the gas
money for for the local family is that
one of the things that you're doing or
are you just jacking up the price of
energy and then kind of throwing up your
hands and saying you can't do anything
about it which is what the binding
administration is actually doing in the
end it comes down to the solipsism of an
elite class who believe that their way
is the only way this is why you get
barack obama waxing poetic about the
images of dystopia in his dreams
there are times where i feel discouraged
there are times where the future seems
somewhat bleak there are times where i
am doubtful that humanity can get its
act together before it's too late
and and then
images of dystopia start creeping into
my dreams
well i mean the the human p the human
people human race has disappointed
barack obama and you will atone okay in
just a second we'll talk about how the
biden administration cannot get out of
this box that they've trapped themselves
in with regard to economics either they
have to keep doubling down they have no
other choice but to double down we'll
get to that in just one moment first
let's talk about something amazing you
can do for yourself and for your family
i'm talking about a special gift for
somebody this holiday season at
paintyourlife.com you can have an
original painting by world-class artist
done by hand from any photo an
affordable price if you want to give a
truly meaningful gift you have to try
paintyourlife.com get a professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo at a truly affordable price
you can send any picture yourself your
kids family a special place cherished
pet you can combine photos in one
painting so let's say you went to a
family port for it but half the family's
on one coast half the families on
another coast you can send the photos to
the painter who will put it all in one
portrait for you with paint your life's
compilation portraits you can bring
together family members who've never
even had the chance to meet choose from
a team of world-class artists work with
them until every detail is perfect you
can get a hand-painted portrait in about
three weeks it's meaningful personal it
can be cherished forever we have a
portrait of our family we need to get a
new one actually we have me and my wife
and two of our three kids we need one
with all three of the kids so we are
going to go back to paint your life and
get a new one right now at
paintyourlife.com there is no risk if
you don't love that final painting your
money is refunded guaranteed and right
now as a limited time offer get 20 off
your painting that's correct 20 off and
free shipping
to get this special offer text the word
ben to 64 000. that's ben to 64 000.
again text the word been to 64 thousand
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most already in just one
second we'll get to the latest round of
spending proposed by the biden
administration first last friday i asked
my facebook followers if joe biden's
authoritarian vaccine mandate would
result in a loss of their job the
response was kind of shocking i received
over 45 000 comments detailing the way
this tyrannical government overreaches
affecting everyday american citizens who
are being forced to bend the knee one
brave woman wrote that after 12 years of
honorably serving our country she's now
out of work another woman shared that
after 20 years of service her husband is
being kicked out of the u.s army corps
of engineers in between these stories
were thousands of others from railroad
workers to healthcare professionals to
college students we filed a lawsuit
because we need to stop all of this it
needs to be stopped the object
administration does not have the
constitutional or statutory authority to
force employers to fire their employees
for not getting vaccinated for covet 19
especially at a time when everyone can
get the vaccine and vaccines are very
protective and so are therapeutics the
lawsuit alleges the bite administration
does not have any of that authority to
issue that employer mandate and that the
mandate failed to meet the requirements
for issuing a rule taking effect
immediately without the normal process
of considering public comments and
that's a major risk to us because we are
not going to comply we could be charged
up to 136 000 per violation the stakes
in the battle are high for us and they
are high for you as well so if you're in
a position to support our lawsuit please
consider joining us by becoming a daily
wire member today your membership is
really helpful not just because you get
all of our great content but also it
helps us do the things that we want to
do to help you and to help the country
right we're a cause driven company
your membership basically allows us to
go out and do the things that we need to
do to fight for freedom in the country
go to dailywire.com subscribe enter code
do not comply at checkout you will
receive 25 off your membership now for
some good news we're launching daily
wire now which means you'll be able to
stream all your favorite daily wire
shows on vizio smartcast tune in watch
candace discuss current events with
guests like donald trump and dana white
or catch one of your favorite hosts you
know me there's always something
interesting to stream watch daily wire
now exclusively on vizio watch free plus
streaming app on channel 162 to access
the content you love 24 hours a day
seven days a week only on vizio
smartcast
also it's been a year since joe biden
was elected president it's time to
unpack everything the democrats have
screwed up since then and the pushback
that we are helping to lead tune in
tomorrow to catch an all-new episode of
backstage we'll discuss the turning of
the tie join me jeremy boring michael
mills matt walsh and andrew clavin
tomorrow 7pm eastern 6 pm central on
dailywire.com and on our youtube channel
daily wire you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
now meanwhile the democrats again they
they have an agenda and that agenda has
trapped them because the american people
it turns out do not like the agenda they
completely misread the temperature they
completely misread the room so they
continue to push build back better even
though there is no taste for bill back
better what exactly is the incentive
right now for kirsten cinema and joe
manchin both of whom are super
vulnerable to vote in favor of a build
back better plan which doesn't actually
cost 2 trillion bucks it costs more like
4 trillion and is going to drive up the
deficit in massive ways to do a bunch of
spending that nobody is really demanding
at this point and the moderates are
starting to buck josh godheimer who's a
vulnerable democrat in new jersey he
says uh we need a full analysis to build
back better before we take a vote on
this thing
i think what's most important for people
to understand is the the responsible
thing to do when you get a piece of
legislation like this is to do a full
analysis and to understand uh the impact
on your district and the families in
your district and that's that's what i'm
looking at to make sure that when we
vote for this uh and and give the
country this win that we deliver the way
we should deliver and so there's so much
in there that matters for my district
you know from reinstating salt and
lowering taxes as i said to child care
to pre-k so we want to get this done
by the way how high are the tax rates
going to be if this bill passes in some
of the blue states the the tax rates are
going to be well upwards the top tax
bracket would be well upwards of 60
in the top tax bracket okay this is an
insane bill it is filled with crap
nobody is actually interested in passing
it if you are a moderate and you want to
pass it it's because you're insane like
you you really have no
data whatsoever to suggest that the
american people are going to resonate to
you passing this massive spending bill
mitch mcconnell is correct when he says
that the democrats have already produced
inflation and now they're pledging to do
more
what they've done already is produce
rampant inflation i mean i want to ask
for a show of hands of how many of you
have been to the grocery store lately
and notice what's going on here the
price of everything is going through the
roof
the american people said basically said
last music stop
enough is enough
okay but they're not stopping
at the same time they can't push it
through because they just do not have
the the crowd to do it according to
politico democrats are about to run into
another buzz saw here
they say quote the senate's year-end
to-do list is going to be a train wreck
as mark warner considers the senate work
left undone as the holiday season dawns
he's weighing a couple of potential ugly
scenarios having only other senators to
kiss on new year's eve the virginia
democrat deadpans about the upcoming
december pileup the only thing that
might be worse would be opening each
other's stockings on christmas eve the
senate is only scheduled to be in three
weeks for the rest of 2021 with a recess
start to set set to start december 10th
there's almost no chance that schedule
holds at this point the democratic
majority is facing a to-do list more
daunting than a black friday sales rush
congress has to fund the government past
december 3rd pass a massive defense
policy bill finish out a 1.75 trillion
party-line social spending bill and
potentially maneuver around u.s credit
default each of those four bills could
take several days of senate floor time
not to mention the myriad negotiations
still left to hash out biden's gop free
domestic agenda with senator joe manchin
who wants to slow things down
it's gonna be a train wreck says senator
john thune republican of south dakota
the minority whip
now again remember the biggest thing
that is on the calendar that is a
problem for the democrats is that come
early december we hit the debt ceiling
again so you'll remember that about a
month ago there's this big talk about
how republicans were going to not vote
in favor of increasing the debt ceiling
and democrats were trying to blame
republicans for not increasing the debt
ceiling even though they have the
singular power to do so by themselves
and mcconnell said you know what i'll
give you guys a chance i'll give you
guys a chance we'll push it off for a
couple of months then it's up to you
that gives you a couple of months to
jabber with each other about build back
better and see if you can do it without
going to reconciliation and if you have
to use reconciliation then you're gonna
have to use reconciliation you're gonna
have to fire that bullet
now the reason democrats don't wanna do
reconciliation with regard to the debt
ceiling increase is because when you do
reconciliation for a debt ceiling
increase apparently this allows what's
called the voteramo where republicans
bring up a lot of unpopular
bills and force democrats to vote in
favor of them or bring up a lot of
popular bills and force democrats to
vote against them and democrats don't
want to be on record doing any of that
but if democrats run up against the debt
ceiling it's gonna be very difficult for
them to make the case that it's
republicans fault this time because
mcconnell literally said to them we're
happy to give you this leeway but come
december 3rd it's on you again
prior to leaving for this week's recess
senators acknowledged it's possible they
have to consider a defense policy bill
before a social spending bill given some
of the outstanding hiccups they face in
fighting for biden's agenda
not just that
the debt ceiling is a disaster area
democrats are not even talking yet about
how they'll address the debt ceiling i
don't know why they're not it's november
9th they've got like three weeks to get
this done
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
is insisting democrats will need to
raise the debt ceiling along party lines
this time after he ascends into a
short-term patch that means using the
so-called reconciliation process to
evade a gop filibuster but schumer is
saying that he's now going to beg the
republicans again
he's saying that he's got
okay mcconnell caves on that
then mcconnell should be in real
political trouble he should not cave on
this he has said already that it's
democrats problem he already gave them
the leeway if democrats want to avoid
this they can do it and if they want to
default on the debt then that's their
problem at this point the treasury
department says it can cover the
country's balance sheet through at least
december 3rd the same day the government
runs out of funding but the bipartisan
policy center which forecasts the debt
limits brink predicts the date could
instead range from mid-december to
mid-february giving lawmakers a little
more time if they have to hit that
emergency
but
democrats are
democrats they know that the squeeze is
coming
okay so it's gonna be a rough few weeks
here for democrats they do not have the
ability to press this thing through and
as i say republicans should be held
accountable they shouldn't have given
biden his infrastructure plan it's
ridiculous that they gave him this by
the way it is such a lie that america
requires trillions of dollars in federal
infrastructure spending it's so
ridiculous and by the best available
estimates the vast majority of hard
infrastructure like highways and bridges
all that stuff
is basically owned by the states the
amount of federal
funding necessary to do that stuff is
not even close to 1.2 trillion dollars
you do understand that on a state
federal and local level the united
states does spend hundreds of billions
like 300 billion dollars every year on
upkeep for highways and streets and
bridges the notion that all of our
bridges and highways are crumbling is
ridiculous most federal infrastructure
at this point is things like dams and
levees
okay that is not the sort of stuff that
the federal government needs to be
spending 1.2 trillion on the republicans
went for it anyway mitch mcconnell he
gets to compromise once on the
infrastructure bill he does not get to
compromise on the debt ceiling at this
point
right mcconnell yesterday for example
was praising the the bipartisan
infrastructure plan
um
i mean honestly like this should not
have been pushed by republicans giving
biden this victory was a big mistake
i was delighted that the house finally
found a way to pass the instructor bill
last week
the president if he hasn't signed it yet
i'm pretty sure we'll soon be signing it
and this will be
the first time i've come up here in a
quarter of a century when
i thought maybe there was a way forward
on the brent spence bridge
okay once again one of the big problems
with congress it always comes down to
can i get pork for my hometown so mitch
mcconnell's talking about the pork for
his home state
yeah that is not the way that congress
was originally designed to run okay
meanwhile
i do want to bring you a piece of news
that i think is really worthwhile and
good
so
a bunch of people who i am personally
friendly with
have decided that they are going to
launch a new university i think this is
great to understand why you have to
understand that right now universities
are largely a scam unless you're in an
engineering program unless you're in
science technology engineering and math
universities are basically a scam
according to a piece by preston cooper
in the wall street journal college is
expensive but worth it or is it college
graduates generally make more money than
those without a degree
but a closer look reveals that for many
the benefit is not spread equally and a
significant minority of students are
worse off for having gone to college in
a report for the foundation for research
on equal opportunity
i calculated the return on investment
for nearly 30 000 different bachelor's
degree programs i estimated the median
lifetime earnings for graduates of each
program based on education department
and census data subtracted tuition costs
and wages missed while enrolled i then
compared that number with a scenario in
which those students didn't attend
college using the earnings of high
school graduates as a baseline and then
adjusting for demographics cognitive
ability and family background as a
result i was able to compare the net
boost in lifetime earnings students got
from each college degree
the results show that 28
of college degrees almost a third
weighted by enrollment do not have a net
positive return
more than a quarter of students are in
programs that are actually a net loss
for them
those students often obsess over where
they get in majors have the most way
over future earnings i've talked about
this at length whenever people say that
there is a
racial differential in college graduates
and earnings
you have to adjust for the majors black
students tend not to engineer not to
major in engineering as much as asian
students for example so you're going to
get a wide variance in terms of earning
potential somebody with an education
degree does not earn the same as
somebody with an engineering degree
programs in engineering computer science
economics and nursing all yield a high
return often increasing their students
net lifetime earnings by half a million
dollars or more but a majority of
programs in art music philosophy and
psychology leave their average students
financially worse off
so if you were given the financial
choice between going to a college and
majoring in philosophy and not going to
the college and getting a job
you're better off in all likelihood not
going to college
a majority of those programs leave
average students financially worse off
some students defy averages of course
there are some music majors who will get
rich and some engineers who will fail
but
that is not the average
one of the nation's highest return
programs is the computer science major
at harvard that degree has an expected
value of more than three million dollars
but attending the nation's most elite
school is no guarantee of financial
security harvard's ethnic and gender
studies program leaves its students
worse off by about forty seven thousand
dollars on average according to these
estimates
so if you major in lesbian dance theory
at harvard you actually lose money
because who the hell wants to hire a
lesbian dance theory major from harvard
besides major another important factor
for negative return is low completion
rates if a student graduates in four
years the increase in earnings is
usually enough to justify the cost of
college but if you take five or six
years to graduate then the cost of
tuition and time spent out of the labor
force start to add up
if you fail to graduate at all you're
stuck with most of the cost of college
but few of the benefits and by the way
there's a huge dropout rate at america's
universities
so if you look
at um the full cost of educations and
not just the education but also
all of the other costs
like the the subsidies that that
colleges pay for student education
you share a bachelor's degrees programs
and negative returns is all the way up
to 37 percent so almost four in ten
bachelor's degrees are less worth are
worth less than the money spent on the
degree okay so what does this mean well
it means that we need to radically
change how education is done in the
united states it means that the promise
of university is basically a lie for a
huge number of people i've been talking
about this for a long time and i'm
speaking as a graduate of some
prestigious universities at ucla and
harvard law school and as i've said
harvard law school is worth the money
because you finish up and now you're a
lawyer from harvard and that means
you're gonna make a lot of money a
policy side degree from from ucla
maybe it's worth the money and maybe
it's not that one is a lot more dicey
and there's a case to be made that we
really should do is move toward a system
where you go directly from high school
into an apprenticeship program if you
want to be a lawyer for example because
what you actually pick up in a poli-sci
program at ucla has almost nothing to do
with what you're learning in law school
at least in the first year there's also
a good case to be made that law school
should be two years rather than three
but credentialing has become the thing
credentialing is a big thing in american
life and the reason for that is we
refuse to look simple facts in the face
if those facts include the fact that
some people are smarter and work harder
than others and so instead of just
recognizing that which you can tell
right out of high school we have decided
to create an airstats method for
evaluating whether people are likely to
be good employees or not
so if you give me somebody like anybody
if you meet their sat scores and their
gpa from high school
i can say with a high level of certainty
whether this person will be a good
employee or not
i don't need that person to go to a
four-year college to tell me that and i
especially don't need them to go waste
two hundred thousand dollars in a
four-year college majoring in english in
order to tell me whether they'll be a
good employee or not in fact i would
rather hire the kid directly out of high
school if they have a good sat score and
a good gpa
and good values and have them go to a
college where they're really just being
indoctrinated into the language of
wilkerness and so this is why it's one
of the reasons why i'm excited about the
launching of this new university it's
called university of austin
pano canelos is the new head of
university of austin he was the
president of st john's college in
annapolis
and it's got a lot of people who i think
are just wonderful they're launching
this college the four-year degree is not
available just yet they're going to
start with some unaccredited programs
then they're going to roll out the
accredited programs in the near future
it's exciting stuff because this needs
to happen competition is the way forward
here panel canals writes
so much is broken in america but higher
education might be the most fractured
institution of all there's a gaping
chasm between the promise and the
reality of higher education yale's motto
is lux at veritas light and truth
harvard proclaims that veritas young men
and women of stanford are told the lift
the free height wet the wind of freedom
blows these are soaring words but in
these top schools and in so many others
can we actually claim that the pursuit
of truth remains the highest virtue so
we honestly believe that the crucial
means to that end freedom of inquiry and
civil discourse will prevail when a
liberalism has become a pervasive
feature of campus life the numbers tell
the story as well as any anecdote you've
read in the headlines or heard within
your own circles nearly a quarter of
american academics in the social
sciences or humanities endorse ousting a
colleague for having the wrong opinion
about hot button issues like immigration
or gender differences over a third of
conservative academics and phd students
say they had been threatened with
disciplinary actions for their views
four out of five american phd students
are willing to discriminate against
right-leaning scholars according to a
report by the center for the study of
partisanship and ideology
the picture among undergrad stephen
bleecker and heterodox academy's 2020
campus expression survey 62 of sampled
college students agreed that the climate
on their campus prevented students from
saying things they believe nearly 70
percent of students favor reporting
professors if the professor says
something students find offensive
according to a challenge institute for
global innovation survey the foundation
for individual rights in education
reports at least 491 disinvitation
campaigns since 2000 roughly half
successful
the reality is that many universities
writes
pano canelos the new head of university
of austin
he says the reality is that many
universities no longer have an incentive
to create an environment where
intellectual descent is protected and
fashionable opinions are scrutinized
the priority of most other institutions
is simply to avoid financial collapse
they're in a desperate contest to
attract a dwindling number of students
who are less and less capable of paying
skyrocketing tuition over the last three
decades the cost of a degree from a
four-year private college has nearly
doubled the cost of a degree from a
public university has nearly tripled the
nation's students owe 1.7 trillion
dollars in loans
and by the way nearly 40 percent of
people who are pursuing a college degree
don't get one
okay so to go back to the stats that
means that 40 percent of people who
pursue a college degree are out
of the remaining 60 percent about
one-third are going to spend more money
on the college degree than the degree is
worth
so that means college is a really really
bad bargain at this point
so
say the folks at university of austin
as i write this i'm sitting in my new
office in balmy austin texas where i
moved three months ago from my previous
post as president of st john's college
in annapolis i'm not alone our project
began with a small gathering of those
concerned about the state of higher
education niall ferguson barry weiss
heather heing joe lonsdale arthur brooks
and i and we have since been joined by
many others including the brave
professors mentioned above kathleen
stock dorian abbott peter bogosian we
count among our numbers university
president robert zimmer larry summers
john nunez gordon g leading academics
stephen pinker deirdre mccloskey leon
cass jonathan height glenn lowry joshua
katz vicki sullivan jeffrey stone bill
mcclay and tyler cowan we're joined by
journalists and public intellectuals
like lex friedman andrew sullivan rob
henderson caitlin flanagan david mamet
ion hersey elisabe stacy hawk jonathan
rouch and nadine strassen
our backgrounds and experiences are
diverse our political views differ what
unites us is a common dismay at the
state of modern academia and a
recognition we can no longer wait for
the cavalry and so we must be the
cavalry
so this is really exciting stuff
it's really great so their plan is that
they are going to be
moving through the next few years
beginning to launch degree programs just
a couple of years from now
and honestly
like all support to them it's great
they're hoping by 2022 to launch a
graduate program in entrepreneurship and
leadership by 2023 to launch graduate
programs in politics and applied history
and in education and public service and
then by 2024 just three years from now
to establish a full undergraduate
college
which is fantastic it's fantastic and so
i encourage everybody to go check out
uaustin.org that is the place where this
is located more of these options for our
students more of these options for our
kids
again competition is the lifeblood of
intellectual development and i am very
excited that that university of austin
is launching and congrats to all my
friends who are involved with that
particular effort alright we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content coming up soon as the matt
wall show it airs at 1 30 pm eastern be
sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show